the beat one of the honorees is very
very humbling to me I'm gonna buy a
couple of copies Gayle King on the
coveted time 100 list of the 100 most
influential people in the world and
director Ava Duvernay calling Gayle
quote one of the all-time great
broadcast interviewers and I didn't
think that her best friend Oprah would
agree and the pair is back with another
edition of their hip
old magazine series the og chronicles
and they are dyed and deep and a family
drama we like to help we like to help
y'all okay resolve your trickiest family
dilemmas okay let's go years ago I think
I'd been dating since Stedman I don't
know I've been dating him since 1775 so
we've been together a long time but we
early on in our relationship I was doing
these shows with my sister slept with my
sister's husband my sister slept with my
boyfriend and all that and Gayle said if
you ever catch me in Stedman in bed she
shouldn't even be mad at me because she
should say I've lost my mind take me to
the hospital yeah that I would know it
goes call someone yes put me in the
jacket bag you have me carried off cuz
you will know that I had lost my mind
that's just that you just yeah and what
would they advise this old readers
question on a tricky parenting problem
I'm still breastfeeding I caught my
mother-in-law feeding my daughter
formula no that's not good how do I tell
them thank you next how do I tell them
thank you for the advice but she is my
child your mother-in-law is wrong she
should not be giving your baby formula
Oprah is pretty in pink on the May issue
of Oh magazine and this is her take on a
relative asking for money you get to
decide you do how much of your salary
your time your energy you want to give
to the family you make that decision and
they have to be okay with it and if
they're not that's okay well a big
congratulations to Gayle who is a good
friend and is so deserving of all the
recognition
[Music]
[Applause]